You know,
my entire schooling and
all my professors were,
each one of them was,
I would say we're radically left.
I don't think I had a central professor.
All my supervisors and colleagues
have been very strong leftist,
social justice warrior
types of radical feminists.
And I always say to people
that it astonishes me when,
um,
that Laurie a video came out and those
professors called showing your video
quote Hitler.
Like I was absolutely astonished because
out of every professor I've ever had,
almost every person I've ever met.
And these are very leftist
people who clean compassion.
You have taken the strongest stance that
of everyone I've ever met on atrocities
of the 20th century Nazi Germany,
uh,
Stalin's regime.
Um,
what happened in the Soviet Union.
You are always warning people
about the dangers of that path.
You are the one that writes about,
it,
speaks about it,
talks about it,
tweets about it,
emails about it,
and yet you were referred to,
um,
and compared to when most
evil people in human history.
And,
um,
of course,
Einstein.
But I'm wondering your
feelings around that.
Well at some point the accusations
gets so absurd that it's just surreal.
Yeah.
You can't even take it
personally because it's so crazy.
Yeah.
I mean,
I've spent a lot of time talking to
my students about and on videos about
Stalin,
but equal amounts of time talking about
the Holocaust and Nazi Germany and
taking it apart and trying to indicate
to people how lapses in personal
responsibility paved the road for four
totalitarian atrocity essentially.
And yeah,
it's really amazing to
have done all that work.
And then to be subject to that kind of,
what would you call it?
Well,
character assassination,
and it's even more amusing with,
well the Wilford,
but what I've learned over the last year,
at least in part Serena,
is that to be patient
with this sort of thing,
because what's happened so far
is every time I've been attacked,
the attackers in validate themselves.
You know,
I feel like I'm in a judo like position
because I think it's in judo where your
attackers momentum against themselves,
you just roll with the punches,
you know?
And that's worked out incredibly well.
Wilfred Laurier is handling the Lindsay
Shepherd affair so badly that you
couldn't script it worse.
I was watching the agenda.
I don't know.
I think you must have seen
that episode where they had,
uh,
Janice Stein.
Yeah.
Professor Walcott.
And um,
of course your name came up and I was,
I was really hoping you were
there to give your position,
but I found
I'm going on the agenda in January.
That's great.
That's that they're going to grill me,
they're going to roast me over the coals.
So,
which is a good thing I think.
Yeah.
I was really surprised at the comment
by Professor Walcott when he said,
you're not an expert and
you're not qualified to
comment on the issues of gender
or gender and sexual identities,
et cetera.
But yet he is a black man,
is the director of the women's programs.
So how is he qualified to be
in that position as a male?
I don't understand that.
I don't understand that
inconsistent way of thinking.
Well,
I wouldn't,
first of all,
I wouldn't say that consistency is
the hallmark of postmodern thinking.
It's whatever argument goes at the time.
And Yeah,
I thought w Walcott's performance on the
agenda was absolutely reprehensible as
well as his comments about
the white Tas who were,
who were always oppressing,
you know,
professors of color to use those horrible,
that horrible phrase ology that the
radical left seems to insist upon.
You know,
he described the University of Toronto
was a white supremacist organization,
I think four times failing to recognize
entirely that he's hired in a very,
let's call it the privileged
position at that university,
and the mere fact of his positioning
is indication for the fall.
So of his claims.
Any sense would see
all you have to do is pick any building
at u of t downtown and just go walk
through the hallways.
Anybody that suggests that it's a
white supremacist institution is,
is not thinking clearly.
They're out of there.
Their
mind.
I was,
I was just at the university yesterday
and I drove by a bunch of students who
were standing outside waiting to
take their exams and if anything,
the Caucasian kids were in the minority.
It's really true at the University of
Toronto and increasingly true and very
rapidly,
increasingly true.
Certainly women or men are in the
minority already out by a large margin,
a dangerously large
margin in my estimation,
but the idea that that that you could
call it the University of Toronto,
which I think you'd have to think,
I really believe this,
that you'd be hard pressed to go anywhere
in the world and find an organization.
It's actually done a better
job of integrating such a
tremendously diverse range
of people into a functioning unit
in the University of Toronto.
I think you could just say some positive
things about u of t two last year they
wrote me a couple of letters asking
me to keep my mouth shut basically,
and which I think was a strategic error,
but they did host the debate afterwards,
which was a good thing.
And I would also say that the University
of Toronto seems to have come down
pretty firmly on the side
of free speech since then.
And I also feel that my position
there as a professor is in no danger
whatsoever,
despite the fact that,
you know,
every couple of months,
200 of the usual usual suspects find it
necessary to write a petition claiming
that I've done something reprehensible
and that the university should fire me.
But there's no,
I don't feel that my position
is in danger there at all.
So.